we got the story from cbs news defense
expert found floyd's manner of death to
be
undetermined not homicide it's actually
quite simple and this is a huge
win for the defense granted it's
literally their witness
you combine this with the prosecution's
witnesses
i don't see how you have anything but
extreme doubt like i'm i'm not
reasonably doubting this
i'm doubting this i've been watching the
the derrick chauvin trial
and i watched the state the prosecution
i watched them
plead their case and i heard their
witnesses
they could not tell us definitively how
george floyd died
so think about this for two seconds they
have charged derek chauvin with
murder quite literally saying you
intended to kill this man and the
defense asks
how did he kill him and the and the
state goes well i mean it could have
been a bunch of different ways we're not
entirely sure what we're accusing him of
but we do know that something he did
killed the guy if the state can't tell
the jury
here's exactly what he did then how can
i definitively say beyond a reasonable
doubt he killed somebody was that on
cross or
direct it was on uh it was actually it
was actually on direct
so check this out they didn't prep with
the guy well no no here's the issue
here's the issue
i guess what happened was initially in
the trial the prosecution said the knee
on the neck
cut off flow of like blood to the brain
and then on cross
they were like oh well you know there's
possibly other reasons
so it seems then and i'm getting this
from some of the legal analysis from
lawyers who know more than i
that they switched up their their
assessment saying well maybe it was
because of the pressure on the neck and
back
making it harder for him to breathe the
state actually brought up
different reasons why it may have
occurred the defense
very smart kept poking at the states
witnesses saying like
man when they got the medical the
medical medical examiner this was huge
the defense says the medical examiner if
you found george floyd in his apartment
how would you think he died and she was
like drug overdose exactly if you had no
drugs in a system
heart disease wow so so like
the left is saying yeah but that's a
hypothetical and it's like dude
the medical examiner is saying that she
could have reasonably concluded had she
not seen the video it was something else
that's called doubt exactly so then we
had that other big moment where
the state's own witness testified and i
i know you guys have heard me say it a
lot because you really got to drive this
one home
i really gotta grab this one home the
use of force expert from la
said derrick chauvin would have been in
the right to tase george floyd the
moment he arrived on scene and he chose
not to
and so the defense was like so chauvin
realized he would use a lesser force
option
and that was the state's witness that
said that you expect me to believe
beyond a reasonable doubt joben intended
to kill floyd
when their own state witness said he
chose lesser force options
i'm sorry dude that's not that's not
doubt they definitively
have proven he did not mean to kill
floyd now we have today's witness who
straight up said it wasn't a homicide
he's a he's a very prominent medical
examiner he's not from hennepin county
he's from maryland
he's paid to be there by the defense so
take into consideration they ask him
this they say you're paid to be here
just so everyone knows
and he says here's his rate was like 350
an hour and he was like
you've got a heart condition george
floyd's got 90
narrowing of like the prominent blood
vessels or whatever he's got
methamphetamine which causes heart
arrhythmia fentanyl which depresses the
respiratory system
and combine that with the restraint you
could not reasonably conclude what
caused the death he said
some would argue being put in the prone
position
was the homicide however taking all of
all the factors into play considering
that you know putting someone in the
proposition isn't going to kill them
i could not say this is a homicide so
this is this is a this is like a
medical examiner legit saying it well
and this is the point it's not even
about
saying directly that no we know for a
fact this is a
not a homicide all you have to do is
establish reasonable doubt as you've
discussed
so people are looking at this like oh
well based on what we saw in the videos
and based on other medical evidence
or whatever they want to tout it appears
as if he was killed okay but if you can
establish a reasonable doubt that he was
not intentionally murdering him then he
can't be charged with it
people are going to write if that
doesn't happen people know this is their
minds
at least not second degree right like
third degree and manslaughter aren't
aren't intentional third degrees out oh
i i in my opinion i'm not a lawyer
okay legal insurrection has been doing a
really great job with their analysis
because i watch the trial i read the
mainstream media and then i read legal
insurrection
and the reason i say they're doing a
good job is you read them and i think
this is andrew bronke i believe his name
yeah
when you read him he's like here's what
the prosecution did well here's where
the defense did really well the
prosecution messed this up this was good
for the prosecution and i'm like that
seems like a fair analysis yeah you turn
the mainstream media
and it's like the defense is a clown
rolling around like dancing
and not actually defending him it's
crazy reading what the left and what the
mainstream press is saying about this
case
because i literally today i'm watching
this
i'm watching the trial live and the
medical examiner said
i would not rule as a homicide it's
undetermined i did not read that
anywhere i listened to the man say it
and i was like wow a medical exam expert
an examiner who's written
apparently written studies from maryland
is here testifying as an expert saying
based on these facts
and he didn't say george floyd died from
drugs or a heart attack he said
he thinks that his heart stopped with
these factors compounding it
can't determine what whether it was you
know it's undetermined and i'm like
that's a fair assessment it's balanced
you see that from legal insurrection you
don't see it from the mainstream media
i'll tell you this though
there will be riots 100 because my
prediction is
first it's possible that because of the
ongoing dante right riots
the jury is terrified and they're going
to be like i'm saying guilty screw that
i didn't get my house burned down
we saw the city council member in
brooklyn center
vote to fire the city manager and say
publicly i was scared of retaliation
that lady should be fired removed
impeached whatever
and that guy should get his job back
immediately because of vote under duress
yeah
but now what's gonna happen is they're
wrapping the defense testimony tomorrow
defense's case wraps tomorrow friday is
a day off
this is the presumed schedule the
weekend the jury is chilling
and then come monday they get
sequestered for deliberations what's
going to happen this weekend
mass riots dante right mass riots so now
these jurors are going to be sitting
there for the weekend stu and watching
the city burn to the ground
and you think they're going to come and
vote vote vote not guilty now here's
what i think might happen
they'll come back and they'll say in the
charge of murder in the second degree we
find derek chovan not guilty
stop the presses the journalists round
the door and say chauvin found not
guilty
then they'll say in the murder in the
third degree guilty manslaughter guilty
assault guilty
but as long as they get one headline
that says
derek chovin found not guilty in murder
you know murder charge in death of
george floyd
it's not the full context but it's
framing that will generate traffic for
the news outlets
you know they're going to take it and
the activists are going to start
screaming
and crying and they're going to go
outside and they're going to burn the
city of the ground
no it's despicable the way the media
behaves is entirely irresponsible and
it's hilarious because for years
they were claiming that the president of
the united states and conservatives were
making them feel unsafe
but then when the country is a powder
gig it seems as if they're doing
everything they possibly can to rile up
tensions even more so
and set the whole thing ablaze that
sounds about right yeah
that's that's the that's pretty much
thinking about kamala harris like in
almost inciting the violence last year
you mean when she was like give me money
to get these people out of jail and back
on this yeah literally
now can you imagine if trump had bailed
out a single person who rushed the
capital or attacked the capital that's
all we'd be hearing about
i mean we're still we're still hearing
about it's still kind of all we're
hearing about yeah and he didn't do that
you know we we did this google search
the other day for riots this was like
monday i think
yeah and google shows you capital rights
capital rights capital riots
and you go on duckduckgo and even bing
and you get minnesota
the big one was the hilarious one like
bing is more reliable than google
not like i'm a fan of microsoft right
now like that but duckduckgo is pretty
good
it's remarkable to me that there are
still people in media even youtubers
they put out videos the other day like
what is trump doing i'm like
i don't know yeah it's it's trump like
in minnesota planning a coup
tim yeah taking the country down is uh
is uh manslaughter considered homicide
yes okay
yeah homicide just means that a person
killed a person it doesn't mean it was
murder it doesn't mean
so this is what happens right the
they're like the medical examiner has
ruled george floyd's death the homicide
and then all the activists go and start
screaming
because they think homicide means
intentional murder
then what happens is you know in these
cases with cops they'll it'll be all the
homicide because the cop
let's say a cop shoot somebody in
self-defense cops walking down the
street whistling to jaunty tune and the
guy jumps out and says haha kappa i'm
gonna kill you so the cop shoots him
first
then the medical examiner says the
person died it was a homicide
the activists say the medical examiner
said it was a murder
why isn't he going to prison because
they don't understand the difference
yeah so you get rights well no this is
actually a failed state because we have
trials for these kinds of things
well yeah and we all we all are big fans
of the great philosopher chelsea handler
yes who who in her glowing wisdom said
why are we even having a trial we've all
seen the video then we had the nation
which is the lefting publication saying
in a reasonable society there wouldn't
even be a trial
that's what they say about reasonable
societies well they said because he
would take the plea and plead guilty
and i'm like that's not reasonable when
if in this case and wouldn't it's not
reasonable when anyone else does it i
hate that idea of people just pleading
out because they're scared
there are a lot of innocent people get
locked up they just plead guilty i don't
know at this point i'm starting to think
this guy should just walk clean
he did less than what could have been
done by protocol he did something that
he was trained to do
george floyd looked like he could have
died just standing there
he was saying i can't breathe no i'm
just saying look at the guy
right look at the guy the guy did not
take care of himself how old was he
he was probably on his way to dying
anyway right
well i'm just saying like you just look
at all the factors you look at
everything and you're like you know what
this guy's going to walk in a just
society i'm not i'm not a fan of that
argument because there's a lot of old
people who don't deserve to die when
andrew
i'm not saying he deserved to die but
i'm saying the guy committed a crime he
went through the process
the guy he was less than forceful all
the the protocols that were available to
him
he that guy showed restraint it's true
children's shoulder
strength hold on let me i want to
address that comment real quick what i
mean is you said you know george floyd
seemed like he was probably on his way
to die
there are a lot of older people that
were in nursing homes that weren't
literally on their way to die and cuomo
still killed them
so 100 100 just because you're older and
firm doesn't mean you deserve to die i
don't know how that came out
you said george floyd was on his way to
die anyway and i'm like
all right but you know when you talk
about the drugs the heart condition the
methamphetamine which is also a
vasoconstrictor
he takes a respiratory depressant he's
got 90
constriction in his blood vessels
already that dude was trying to kill
himself
he was killing himself or someone else
on the wheel of a car yes
exact fentanyl and no hand meth
i mean this is the combination of the
two behind the wheel of the car
is it's not about himself it's about the
reckless endangerment to himself and
others
and so the cops they stopped him and
there was even uh the medical examiner
today they showed a picture of floyd
with the thing in his mouth
like he's get when the cop pulls him
over you can see something on his tongue
the judge even said it looked like a
pill in september
and so he asked what does that look like
based on what we've heard already looks
like he's swallowing pills
right and we know that the state doesn't
actually want to get to the bottom of
this right because if they really want
to get to the bottom of this they would
be giving the drug dealer immunity to
get the real deal to get
him on the stand but they won't exactly
the state could say maurice lester hall
the dealer they could promise him
immunity
you will be immune from prosecution if
you testify and they won't do it
because as soon as this trial is over
they're going to file charges against
him
well as they should which is actually
something that i've been thinking about
in terms of the calculus it's like
we give this guy immunity he can still
go out there and sell drugs
george floyd clearly was on drugs all
these things we've just talked about
maybe they don't want to burn their
powder on that i don't know it's it's a
thought but like
given the social ramifications the
cultural political ramifications of the
verdict
this for the city for the country they
really should be doing everything they
can to get to the bottom of it but
they're not
you know you know what i saw that was uh
here's the thing though even if they
were able to come out and definitively
prove that we know for a fact he odd
uh the officer in question is completely
innocent chauvin didn't do anything
wrong
i think there would still be riots of
course there's oh yeah so how much yeah
right right even if the even if the
facts were a thousand to zero
they're still gonna be riots if they
took derek chauvin
after a day after this happened and the
riots were breaking out and they marched
into the top of a pyramid
and grabbed his arms and legs and put
him over the shrine and took a giant axe
they would still riot yeah they would
say we're going to write until the
system changes
they would find a reason honestly they
might have write it even more when you
give a mob what they want it doesn't
exactly that's right i'm thinking about
like
like right doing nothing right now is
like
a fire a blaze that's burning through
the fields and you're not gonna do
anything you're just gonna let it keep
burning
but but putting this pariah in this guy
is like pouring gasoline on the fire to
try and put it out you constantly
reignite the tensions and the story and
exacerbate things
yeah so there's other ways to put out a
fire you know you can burn the land
around the fire you can fix the system
itself so it doesn't continue but
if after this incident they said we will
not be charging any of these officers
you'd have had the same riots they would
have ended and there would be no more
news this year
by charging him he is going to get
acquitted on many of these charges
because they're insane and they're going
to reignite the anger yep
i'll tell you something though i want to
mention this i don't know if the defense
are masters playing 4d even
5d chess maybe they're just slipping on
banana peels and then
pulling off backflips that's the joke
like instead of slipping and falling
down you go whoop land perfectly
do that right right right so here's the
defense right
the defense brings on this uh cop who
pulled over floyd in 2019
and he's like let's show the body camera
footage from what happened
and in this body camera footage the cop
is cussing at floyd kind of yelling and
i'm like wow this is like doesn't look
good for this cop yeah george floyd is
like i'm trying man i don't understand
and then that you can hear one of the
other cops yell spit it out spit it out
yep
he takes floyd out of the vehicle custom
and the body camera footage stops and i
was like
what was the point of watching that then
the prosecution starts
and because he's like no no further
questions the prosecution steps up and
says
did george floyd faint no did he fall
down no did he did
did he did he need to go to the hospital
no was he okay
and then they're like george floyd in
this instance you know was panicking
saying i can't breathe but he didn't die
he didn't you know he wasn't killed
so clearly you know in the same
circumstance he was fine
and that was the setup because the
narrative now
is that the prosecution basically stated
george floyd in the past has feigned
medical emergency
to no ill effect to him it looked like
they were saying that
they tried making the argument see when
he was sick before nothing bad happened
and the defense was like see before he
pretended to be sick too
and if nothing happened why should a cop
now reasonable believe he's being
reasonable
in his statements so it was actually
pretty a pretty interesting you know
flip on the prosecution
that they walked right into watching the
prosecution so far
i'm surprised you you have the these
left-wing outlets can even pretend
they're doing well
they had some good days they've had this
initially at the beginning when they
when the judge allowed for a week of
people to just
testify about how horrible it was to
watch like yeah they were doing decently
but then
but so many of their witnesses have said
things that you're like that was a
defense witness right
right right right that's what i'm saying
the prosecution had only i think like
one or two real good days
yeah and and that was just in the last
week on like thursday and friday
where they got the experts to say you
know chauvin killed him
he shouldn't have he shouldn't have used
this force and then on cross from the
defense
they were like eh and it wasn't really
good for the defense and so
some of the analysis is basically that
nelson seems to be tired there's like
multiple prosecutors and only one
you know or one or you know i think one
defense attorney but for the most part
the state's witnesses have constantly
said things where you're like
what introducing doubt on their own
the prosecution it's so bad that you
think that they just didn't even do
prep i've been involved in depositions
in court cases
the lawyers sit down with you for days
they ask you all the questions in the
order they're going to ask you the
questions
they basically give you a flip and
script and then
they have another lawyer cross-examine
you as if they were the the
opposition counsel so either they're
what arrogant they didn't do the prep
it must be it right they just prep or
they don't want shelving to go to jail
because
so the process the prosecution is is is
what's the word when you screw up
the prosecution throwing the fight i
don't know if they're throwing the fight
i think they just don't have a case that
would be that would be noble
i don't think they're throwing the fight
throw that i mentioned it before like
what if they're actually just
flubbing this but the reality is they're
doing the best they can
there's no case should not have been
charged not at all
manslaughter is the only reasonable
charge in the death of george floyd
only reasonable because it's an argument
about whether or not his training
he was negligent in his use of force and
he wasn't so he should be acquitted even
on manslaughter
exactly this is what i think is a
freaking joke when this is a scumbag
doing scumbag things
who died doing scumbag things under the
control of a cop doing the cop things
that he was trained to do
maybe maybe but you don't know i mean he
did have his knee on his neck
oh
but it might have also been on his neck
the testimony has shown that the knee
wasn't consistently on the neck and
moved back and forth consistently
which means this is where i guess the
state was forced to change their
argument because without consistent
pressure on the neck
the argument of cutting off blood flow
made no sense because chauvin's knee
moved several times
so okay well here's how he killed him
if the state can't tell me definitive if
the state came out and said this man
pulled a gun
on video fired it the bullet went the
guy the guy died i'd be like
okay that's their case and i saw the
evidence now they're like we think this
is what killed him
was it was that well actually his knee
moved so it wasn't that but maybe it was
this
bro get your story story straight why
don't you come back after you figured
out exactly what caused this guy to die
giving me a 30-day trial where we argue
about what actually killed the man
if you don't know how do you bring
charges claiming someone did it that's
what's crazy
and again they won't give immunity to
maurice lester hall because
they're probably gonna charge him he's
the one who did it right
you know one of the things that bothers
me yes i think you are right uh
is that there's this there's this desire
to win in court like
like it's it's the prosecution versus
the defense and they both want to win
when they what they should both be doing
is getting to the bottom of the
situation
and trying to bring justice regardless
of who was right and who was wrong
if the prosecution finds out that the
guy wasn't guilty
stop the case stop you know this is what
really bothers me watching law order you
guys watch law order yeah in the
criminal justice system
yes the people are represented by two
equal but you know whatever it's
different
it's annoying when there have been some
there have been some episodes where they
actually
where uh jack the prosecutor in the og
lawn order defies the d.a and dropped
the case and like
he purposefully threw a case against
this woman and she she
burned her building down killed her son
and she did it because she was like
suicidal and desperate and her son was
having a seizure and she thought he died
and so he was ordered to get her on
murder charges and he decided to go for
an extreme charge that wouldn't fly that
the jury would not rule on
and he defied her because he knew it
wasn't justice but that's tv
in reality the prosecutor's like i'll
say whatever i have to say to get my
case
yes we have politics in play and chauvin
should go to prison for the rest of his
life
even though any reasonable person's
gonna look at this and be like maybe
you need to reform the police department
maybe you should stop training people to
do this
well look maybe he was overcharged uh i
don't know the details was that was the
person who decided to charge him the
same person who's prosecuting the case
not really that relevant but there's
multiple prosecutors interesting
question
but like in a in a decent world
without the cultural and political
backdrop
to this case then what's happening is
exactly what we want to have happen
somebody dies cop was involved we do an
investigation and at the end of the day
we're like
cop was fine that's what we want in our
world
but the problem is is the cultural and
political backdrop is such
that we know that justice haha isn't
that funny that these people say they're
after justice
if justice prevails well
goodbye minneapolis did you see the
mayor of brooklyn center
it's a city just outside of minneapolis
he came out and called the group
peaceful protesters thank you peaceful
protesters while wearing a ballistic
helmet i love that
that's that's mostly peaceful protesters
too he's wearing a ballistic helmet
while saying thank you peaceful protest
to protect himself from all of the
right-wing patriots who were there
who were throwing grenades and bottles
and beer that's right no no it wasn't
that he was
he it wasn't wearing it because he was
concerned about his his uh about
violence
he was concerned about the celebratory
peace bricks
thrown in celebrations
so many businesses have just been
blessed by having a peace brick thrown
through their window that's right
beautiful and fires of peace destroying
their people
celebration from from the original uh
george floyd may riots in dc uh there
were decorative bricks
yes giant piles
of decorative no no no no no actual
decorative rocks
about yay big decorative well yeah
because they were like
they were fancy right they had like
specks in them and they were different
colors
and they filled up all of the flower
planters on the corner
of 16th and h which is right black lives
matter plaza whatever
and i just i've been thinking about that
so much lately
there was just just hordes of people
just picking up these like half a brick
size rock each just chucking them
through the windows with these big
office buildings they're just shattering
all the glass and
piece rocks were they there before were
they painted
no they were like that you could tell
they're like expensive like somebody
paid to decorate these planters with
them but they turned out they were piece
bricks
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you